in Sweden they are gonna test out
something that is very unamerican they
want to see if working less will
actually increase productivity that's
right the city government of Gothenburg
Sweden it wants to test the impact of
shorter hours and how that affects
productivity in an experiment that
begins in about three weeks so one group
of government workers in the elderly
care sector are going to work six hours
a day while another are going to work
the eight hours that they're accustomed
to working after a year the government
is going to analyze the results and
decide whether the six hour day actually
allows people to accomplish just as much
as they were doing with two extra hours
of course proponents of cutting the
workday are saying that you know people
have fewer sick sick days and they'll be
more efficient in general and the
International productivity ranking by
Conference Board a non-profit Business
Research Organisation Sweden was already
close to the top coming out 11th in 61
countries in terms of productivity and
we've got some more info on that for you
so this is average work hours and
international productivity rankings okay
so what you can see here is that in the
Netherland they don't work a ton but
they're ranked fifth in productivity
pretty good the United States we do work
a lot an average of roughly 400 more
hours a year than they do in the
Netherlands and we our productivity is
pretty good but interestingly in Chile
and in Mexico they work a ton and their
productivity is not good so there's all
sort of it's a little all over the place
but also I think you can get some
interesting stuff from this so let's
just start with the American component
since we're in America here this is very
unamerican right to say oh you should
work less and maybe that'll make me more
but up because we're just taught to work
and work and work
can we play I'm not working hard it's
working smart so if you're tired and
you're hating life yeah you're gonna
work much more poorly so I kind of see
think Sweden has a point here yeah
should we jump on this bandwagon that
Sweden because I think when they do that
once they get the information back on
this they're gonna see yeah people can
work more nimbly and more swiftly I
think it's it would be a great thing if
people worked for your hours because we
work a ton a lot of like people are
independent contractors nowadays as well
and they're working more than four
5060 hours we have a lot of young
lawyers that are going crazy 100 120
hour week work weeks
I think that's unacceptable but I think
that if we are going to lower the
minimum number of hours for full-time
work from say eight to six we also have
to make some changes so that workers are
engaged and we're getting the same level
of productivity we know that certain
activities that work lead to you know
lead to results and others don't
so that's where we should focus our
energy in making people happier more
engaged at work so all right so let's
talk about happiness because we never
talk about that right that's the that's
the one thing that's never talked about
is the relation between work and
Happiness so they've done studies that
show that people that are working are
generally happier because then you have
money and you can go do things and take
vacations and things like that but we
don't really talk about it on sort of a
day to day basis like where happiness is
coming from and people I'm sure that are
working a hundred hour work weeks
probably not that happy right family
you're not sleeping enough you're not
eating enough you're not seeing your
friends you're not getting the things
done that you need to get done that
aren't even fun at all yeah of course
you're stressed out do you guys think
that as the economy changes and now that
we can do everything online and
computers and things like that that you
could accomplish as much in three hours
as maybe they used to be able to
accomplish all day long so the I so I
feel like a lot of people right now
people that are watching there are a lot
of people watching this at work we know
a lot of the a lot of our videos are
watched during work hours and people are
at work without things to do actually
because it's sort of the old paradigm of
like working 9:00 to 5:00 but actually
you can accomplish all you needed to do
from like 9:00 to 11:00 this idea of
working to like from 9:00 to 5:00 comes
from like the the times of Agriculture
when we had to wake up at a certain time
and then there was light and so we used
up all the valuable light time and then
we went to bed after the Sun set or
whatever so it makes no sense to apply
to like today's society where we have
artificial light where we have the
Internet where we can communicate
globally I think that what's happening
though is that because we have all these
technological advances we just want
people to do more and their bosses
expect more out of us like now like you
know I've so many of my friends tell me
my boss sends me an email at 3 o'clock
in the morning and I'm expected to
respond and I'm like that's [ __ ] nuts
what is it isn't it you get emails at
that hour don't you feel that because I
see it all the time I get email
we got my check way more like 10 I would
get any was like 10 or on the weekends
and get be expected to respond to that
I'm like [ __ ] this like this is not okay
yeah so is that the huge drawback to the
technology because now they're saying
how how people don't even stop working
when they're on vacation now because
everyone has an iPhone and you can
literally yeah on the beach you're like
oh [ __ ]
you know ya know people are like from
worker like I'm in a different state now
no but yeah I can definitely see this I
feel like most of the workday is spent
you know hurry up and wait or wasting
time running out the clock and it
doesn't need to be that way we can enjoy
our lives shockingly enough and we can
enjoy our work also shockingly enough
yes so if Sweden which already as we
said they don't work as much as us and
they are more productive if they find
this to be true and really push this
idea all over the country do you think
they're gonna have an immigration
problem I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure
they don't have the easiest immigration
policies in the first place but really
do you think this is the place people
would be like you know what they're
doing something right they're different
though - they're very much focused on
education much more than you know the
u.s. is and they're also healthier they
have a better educational system they
have a better health system so I think
those two things also highly contribute
to their productivity it's not just
about the hours the fact that they have
a society where even if they're working
for your hours they're still working
great there you go